i don't think anything is going to unite  this conservative party they're tearing  each other apart and what we've got in  the middle of a cost of living crisis is  a government that can't function and  that's why i say he can't cling on now  they've declared him unfit to be prime  minister they can't inflict him on the  country for the next few months if they  don't get rid of him we will bring that  vote of no confidence  in the national interest because we  can't go on with this broken government  led by this discredited prime minister  enough is enough and the change we need  is not a change at the top of the tory  party it's much more fundamental than  that we need a change of government and  a fresh start for britain